bonsoir rg universitaire avec nous la
sortie homophobe du président c'est un
dérapage vous répond t-il un objectif je
sais pas le premier il ya déjà plusieurs
fois fait des déclarations fracassantes
je vais pas vous faire le florilège
entier villa d'une fois qu'il aimerait
mieux avoir un fils mort qu'un fils gay
il est coutumier de la chose dit stone
est calme depuis quelque temps mais là
il recommence comment perçoivent
justement les brésiliens statique de
sortie le brésil est très divisé un peu
comme les états unis il ya des gens qui
sont indignés mais ils le sont depuis
longtemps et il y en a d'autres qui
trouvent bien tout ce qu'il dit quoi
qu'il dise on a reçoit régulièrement par
les gogos boîte sap de ma belle famille
des cousins et des autres qui disent que
ce qu'il dit est très très bien et donc
le pays est partagé je peux pas vous
dire si c'est 60 40 40 60 mais en tout
cas il masse considérable de brésiliens
qui le suivent qui trouve qu'il a raison
de même que les troupes pistes trouvées
très bien tout ce que disait donald
trump sa cote ne semble pas souffrir de
ces sorties ni d'ailleurs de sa position
sur le virus
vous vous l'analysez comment son
élection était un peu un hasard c'est à
dire que la gauche beaucoup de gens
étaient vraiment complètement opposé au
retour du parti des travailleurs de la
gauche donc c'était tout plutôt que le
parti des travailleurs et ça a suffi à
faire 50 % mais n'a jamais eu 50 % de
gens qui voulaient vraiment l'appuyer
positivement et parmi les gens qui ont
voté pour lui
certains ont déjà considéré qu'ils
avaient fait une erreur qui ne referait
pas mais d'autres s'obstine en disant
non non on a eu raison enfin il essaie
de se convaincre mutuellement qu'ils ont
bien fait que c'était le bon choix et
que donc il fallait rester fidèle à ce
président alors qu'il avait saluée comme
une victoire en tout cas l'arrêt des
essais du vaccin chinois les ont
finalement repris le président ne
minimise pas le virus il
il le nie carrément ce qu'on peut dire
ça il le nie surtout quand il s'agit de
celui qui est développé dans l'état de
sao paulo puisque son le gouverneur
d'état de sang par le probablement sera
son concurrent dans deux ans et donc
tout ce qui peut faire pour embêter
s'opposer à un dogme
donc là il s'est ouvertement réjouis que
ce vaccin qui développait avec les
chinois en plus par un institut de san
paolo échoue en fait il n'a pas échoué
du tout il ya eu un mort dont il a été
prouvé à peu près pouvez maintenant en
tout cas qui s'est suicidée donc j'ai
probablement les essais vont reprendre
vous avez des phillies ont repris j'ai
pas les dernières nouvelles mais tout
cas c'est un accident de parcours ça va
devrait continuer son chemin alors les
chiffres du cor vide ils sont
sous-estimés selon les experts que
sait-on vraiment parle de cent soixante
deux mille morts au brésil et quelque
5,6 millions de personnes contaminées
c'est ce qu'on estime à partir des cas
déclarés mais comme il ya très peu de
tests on n'en sait rien on est un peu
dans la même situation ont fait de vous
il est toujours dans la première vague
il n'a pas fini la première et donc il a
deux il ya moins de tests qu'il ne
faudrait pas tout à fait assez de
masques donc ils sont plutôt dans notre
situation on était en avril mai et donc
il est très vraisemblable qu'il ya
beaucoup de sous dessous
d'enregistrement faut rappeler que la
majorité de la population est très
pauvre il ya beaucoup de mal à accéder
au système de santé public et donc ils
sont pas testés et quand ils vont dans
les hôpitaux
c'est souvent qui sont déjà très malade
donc je pense que le nombre des morts
n'est pas sous-estimer le nombre des
gens affectés mais probablement
aujourd'hui la situation est toujours la
même
pas d'évolution en tout cas dans les
mesures de restriction comment les
choses se passe concrètement sur le
terrain au brésil parce qu'on sait que
les gouverneurs notamment joué un rôle
important dans chaque région où il faut
rappeler que le brésil c'est 15 fois la
france et que c'est un état fédéral donc
chaque état une politique se séparer
comme on vient de le voir aux états unis
et donc ça dépend beaucoup de chaque
gouverneur et même de chaque mère dont
il ya des endroits où c'est très strict
et très respecté il y en a d'autres où
ça ne l'est pas du tout il y en a où il
ya des mesures de façade prises et les
gens font ce qu'ils veulent c'est ce
qu'on a à l'écran ce moment les cas des
os cassés les habitants de rio sont
vraiment pas très disciplinés ils
veulent aller à la plage et donc on a
des situations extrêmement contrastées
mais en tout cas on a pu observer c'est
moi un peu mon travail de jéhovah
l'expansion de la maladie de la atteint
maintenant tout le pays
il n'y a pratiquement plus au pq est
peuplé de quotidienne qu'il ait pas eu
de cas ils n'ont pas tous des morts ce
que les gens souvent sont transférées
dans les hôpitaux des grandes villes
pour mourir mais ça atteint tout le pays
y compris la masoni y compris le
pantanal y compris des régions très
basse densité
merci avait atterri à géographe
professeur à l'université de sao paulo
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france